so I want to say I like a Swiss guy like
Michael cheat on me was in a beeper
telling me he's I you know you know
unless you or whatever you're going to
be so good at this you're gonna be so
good at this I'm glad I wore such tight
trousers how do you beat your chest with
these so hang on gorilla is the art
[Applause]
wolf as a chimp of channeling an animal
is this right oh yeah this is yeah
actually yes you did it was this thing
it's this thing I as as what apparently
some of the greats have done I googled
how do you act one of these things I've
heard people do is that they when like
the trying to just you know you can just
do you which works or you can like maybe
try to manipulate the way you look or
the way you sound or like the rhythm of
who you are that's the things you can
you know kind of tune and change a
little bit and so one of the things that
I was trying to do is like change the
way that I walked a little bit and they
and sometimes you can think of an animal
like what animal would this character be
and I thought of a dolphin because
dolphins like to fight they like to fish
and like the [ __ ] there's the three
things and they're very good at walking
no I I you know I just they lead I just
figured he they kind of lead with their
forehead so I was like my it's a body
lead it's like what part of your body do
you lead with because if you lead with
the shoulder it makes you walk one way
if you lead with your your hips you know
whatever you'd rather you lead with it
can it can change how you carry yourself
and who is Dave the Frog and why is
David frog got something to do with you
Dave the fungus in my mouth this is what
a year what is that story right and so
we have to do red carpets all the time
and take pictures and I find it very
awkward when they're all shouting at you
and stuff and a fan of mine tweeted a
picture of me saying Tom Harlem looks
like he has a frog in his mouth when
he's taking paparazzi pictures and I
thought it was hilarious
so I reposted the picture which then
went viral and everyone found it
hilarious but then weeks go by and I'd
look at myself in the mirror and be like
this is the I think this is the original
tweet this is you I think it's because
I'm trying to go for the chiseled jaw
kind of look is just not working there
is a new thing in this one for both of
you the underwater sequence yeah that
looked hard oh dear that was that was
pretty difficult it was a really
technical probably about a week at
Pinewood because we shot the building
here in in London and it was all
underwater it's the sequence where this
sphere falls off a cliff and she and
another actor by the name of Justice are
stuck inside of the sphere and I'm on
the outside of the sphere trying to
rescue them as it sinks and your water
is filling up the gyrosphere and at one
point we're completely submerged in
water and yeah we went I don't know
maybe a week or eight days or nine days
we spent in water yeah and it was boy
I'll tell you they put a lot of chlorine
in the water because you've got a crew
of eighty-five people just pissing this
people we didn't have time for people to
pee so you knew oh I'm certain
people would certainly just
that was good I killed a little bit when
you you're not supposed to pee in the
pool but no one got out and because I
was I had to be underwater
with my eyes open of course as if I
could see with my eyes open underwater
Chris DGP I actually [ __ ] myself
time is money on a movie like this when
you're in like the young accurate ish
ins the exercise repetitions where you
have a very simple cue and a very simple
line and the Kuehl might be would you
like some more coffee and the line you
have to say is coffee you think I want
more coffee boy do I need more coffee
so if you would say coffee do I want
coffee boy do I need more coffee okay
and you're gonna say it every
conceivable way you kill and all I'm
gonna say is do this would you like more
coffee would you like more coffee coffee
boy coffee boy do I need more coffee
good thank you would you like some more
coffee coffee coffee boy do I need some
all right with a little more something
to it because we need this is this is a
big important see cuz King Kong is out
front he's gonna smash the coffee coffee
please sir I need some more coffee
that's right more coffee coffee please
sir I need some work off with the lights
more coffee coffee coffee please sir
Kalani need some more coffee what do you
like some more coffee coffee please
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah I did the commercial the other day
as Tom Holland and I was like hey guys
how you doing
you're like you're from Kingston you
like getting naked yeah yeah I liked
I've spent a good amount of time naked
yeah yeah but even when you were a kid I
was always getting naked I was always
getting in trouble for getting naked
they're like you can't just pull your
dick out it's like in your sitcom yes
yeah Parks and Recreation the sitcom I
wonder if this is okay I guess it is I
you know basically there was a scene
like in this in the second season of the
show I play this guy who is is
dim-witted and guileless but a real
idiot and-and-and but lovable and and he
lives out in a pit outside of this house
he lives in a hole in a tent and he's
like kind of a homeless guy and and and
he but he got kicked out of his
girlfriend's house anyways long story
short she has invited him to come back
to the house for some reason but I think
it's to hook up so I come back naked and
of course they give you these briefs
that are like like little underwear but
their skin colored because they'll
pixelate it out but now I open a knock
on the door an Amy Poehler's character
opens the door and says sandy and I'm
naked and that's the bit well it was
like late in the day and amy was going
Andy but it to me it didn't seem like
she really was reacting to seeing my
dick drop my trou and an improv show
open the door and then that will be the
take that they will use right by the way
it is the tape
he opens the door and she goes Andy whoa
I ran it by the boom mic operator should
I get naked he was like and then I got a
letter from NBC saying basically never
ever do that again there is a protocol
to being naked you must give everyone
the option to not see it yes there's not
that many people in the room but there's
a camera and behind the camera is a ton
of people watching you know so I got
naked and then and then they sent me a
letter and I framed it I got it right
next I got it in my office I love it and
it's said it said first of all this is
not a joke
you're being reprimanded this is this is
the last warning it can't happen again
and also we don't want you going around
and talking about this letter like it
was something some kind of joke but
Chris Pratt's I hear I hear you are a
magician dude yes I am yeah well I like
like I know real magic yes no these are
not well I know some tricks it's been a
while because these no honestly these
cards Chris didn't bring these cards
they just we got them yeah you know give
you these cards I can do magic real mad
magic yes you have to be very careful
just practicing in the dark arts
lots of flourishes okay okay here we go
now it's been a while oh I screw this up
just you know you'll cut it out yeah
this is a whole new deck I haven't seen
this deck you haven't shown me this deck
you know that this is not a deck of
cards captivated yet so I'm gonna
shuffle it I also played a magician in
the movie The Magnificent Seven I saw
Thank You movies and and so I learned I
got to practice a little bit there okay
I need a volunteer
should I do a card trick for will.i.am I
love my life okay okay so here's what
we're gonna do this is called Burnham
and it works 50% of the time so I'm
gonna make three piles
now will.i.am may I call you will I am
yeah yeah okay yeah um take this card
and pick it up and put it on actually no
put it on either side of these piles you
want face up this card right here Oh
take your that car take that card and
put it face up on either side oh I get
to choose yeah yeah and now take that
card and put it put it there face up
hell yeah now this is your card but do
not let me see it but show everybody
okay
that's your car / - Lucy see it okay ah
come on
and don't say anything oh good car and
when you're and when you're finished
wait committee get to memory put it back
in the middle pile anywhere anywhere
anywhere you want in the middle pot hide
it and make it so that I could never
know where you okay you got it yeah boom
on that is absent absent
now ooh two fours I call this trick two
fours i taked one four on the bottom one
4 on top
now what do I know I know that your card
you remember your card don't tell me
this is somewhere inside this little
deck but I don't know where it is so I'm
gonna put that in the middle let's and
put that right there
now I want you to shuffle that four
times
ah [ __ ] nobody works half the time so if
it doesn't work I'm gonna be really
embarrassed okay
one shuffle mm-hmm two shuffles three
shopping but that's okay let's try now
yeah okay now I'm gonna look cuz I'm
gonna find your car don't don't look at
my process how many chances you get to
find the car though cuz we can sit there
but is I guess four oh you get four
chances yep that seems fair
thirty minutes each yes Graham Norton
Show yeah okay let's see here no no
that's not it oh it's coming it's gonna
be here okay horn I think I got it
nope okay horn I get four chances wait a
second will you count four chances to
just shuffle through them or four
chances to show me you just know you
just look at you looking for your card
I'm looking for your card okay I got it
the first chance yeah boom okay it's
called Burnham I take one I burn it I
might have burned your card will.i.am
your card is it your card yeah just tell
me your card now because this could be
it
what is your card you can tell me now
because I wouldn't be able to take it
out it's an a an a of har a of Hearts
yeah
the ace of hearts and wine no your card
8a is in this pile Sam we wash Azam I'm
not done give me a fist bump wait a
second magic fist bump keep it right
there don't move it squeeze
[Applause]
[Music]
you